deny deny deny has been the strategy at
number 10 downing street over reports of
a staff christmas party last year when
they were banned under covid rules the
government says no rules were broken
leaked video recorded four days later
during rehearsals by senior staff for a
news briefing offers damning evidence to
the contrary
if i went home
hold on hold on um
ah
this fictional party was a business
meeting
and it was not socially distanced
one of those involved has now resigned
it recalled and perhaps eclipsed
previous pandemic rule breaches like
chief advisor dominic cummings lockdown
family road trip the former health
secretary matt hancock's office affair
and the prime minister's own failure to
wear a mask on a recent hospital visit
at prime minister's questions on
wednesday boris johnson was under
extreme pressure to step up his response
i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i was also furious to
see that clip
and mr speaker
i apologize
i apologize unreservedly for the offence
that it has caused up and down the
country and i apologize for the
impression that it gives
it barely took the sting out of the
opposition's attack
her majesty the queen sat alone when she
marked the passing of the man she'd been
married for 73 years
leadership
sacrifice
that's what gives leaders the moral
authority to lead
does the prime minister think he has the
moral authority to lead and to ask the
british people to stick to the rules
that question would be put to the test
later at a news conference boris johnson
announced new public health measures in
response to the highly transmissible
omicron variant
i know this will be hard
for
for many people they include mask
wearing in more indoor settings guidance
to work from home where possible and the
use of vaccine passports in large public
settings it is for the public now to
decide if they will listen
by making his statement and offering his
apology in parliament boris johnson will
have hoped to move events on in a story
that has the potential to do him great
damage the problem is that a new
conversation may now emerge one about
the public's willingness to follow new
measures in the face of the omicron
variant and whether this government has
the moral authority to enforce them
joe nahul al jazeera london